[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
both in the economic and political arena
japan is coming back into fashion what
an example since he arrived in the oval
office joe biden has made it clear that
japan remains the linchpin of u.s
security policy in asia proof of this is
that both secretary of state anthony
blinken and secretary of defense lloyd
austin visited japan on their first
international trip and not only that the
japanese prime minister at the time was
the first foreign guest biden received
as president of the white house quite a
statement of intent and of course it's
not just about the relationship between
tokyo and washington increasing economic
competition from china is causing the
japanese government to step up its game
there is for example the trans-pacific
partnership agreement the cptp one of
the largest free trade and economic
integration agreements in the world that
is being led by none other than japan a
country that according to public opinion
polls is the most trusted power in
southeast asia the world's fastest
growing economic region
but we're not only talking about the
political field the truth is that the
japan is also becoming fashionable
economically despite all its limitations
such as eternal crises the demographic
decline or the weakness of the yen the
land of the rising sun or rather
japanese companies are reinventing
themselves starting in the late 1990s
when first south korean and taiwanese
companies and then chinese ones began to
compete head-to-head with many japanese
manufacturers they were gradually forced
to produce goods that were more
difficult to make and imitate in other
words move up the value chain and that's
exactly what they did many japanese
companies have transformed themselves
into suppliers of high-tech highly
innovative materials and components that
are indispensable in the global
production chain
[Music]
to give you an idea although for us end
consumers it may be somewhat invisible
japanese companies control more than 50
of the market share and many of the
advanced components and supplies of
high-tech industry from specialty glass
to semiconductor manufacturing equipment
to complex chemicals if you use
high-tech products japan probably has a
lot to do with it in many ways this
explains how since 2009 japan's real per
capita growth has grown almost at the
level of the united states and has riven
above countries like france or the
united kingdom
[Music]
yeah that's right japan's gdp is barely
growing but we have to take into account
that its population particularly that of
working age has been shrinking for years
in other words with a lower population
they produce more in per capita terms
japan's economic performance over the
last decade has been reasonably good
[Music]
and if we also take into account that
it's still the third largest consumer
market in the world after the united
states and china we can get an idea of
why japan's economy is once again
attracting the attention of
multinationals however hold on just a
minute because something is not adding
up despite all its attractions the truth
is that international companies barely
invest in japan check this out
but having said that let's move on
why is nobody investing in japan
well to say that nobody invests in japan
is obviously a bit of an exaggeration
but surely you won't think it's such an
exaggeration if i tell you the united
nation ranks japan second to last in the
world only to north korea in terms of
foreign direct investment received as a
percentage of gdp this is a huge anomaly
the bottom line is that fdi accounts for
just over 4 of japan's gdp to give you
an idea the average for developed
countries is 44
normally countries that want to boost
their economic growth would encourage
foreign companies to locate their open
new facilities such as factories or new
offices to buy local companies or invest
in the country's public or private bonds
however this is not the case in japan
which remains completely disconnected
from foreign direct investment flows but
does that mean it is forbidden to make a
productive investment in the land of the
rising sun not all in fact japan's
politicians have been talking about
encouraging foreign investors for almost
20 years and in a way they have done
just that
[Music]
when koizumi took office as prime
minister in 2001 fdi in the country was
a mere 1.2 percent of gdp prompting the
government to set a target of 5 by 2011.
at first things went smoothly and the
percentage of foreign investment
increased to 4 in 2008 since then
however things have remained stagnant so
the question is what is the reason for
this anomaly why does japan not attract
productive investment why does nobody or
almost nobody want to invest in this
country how is it possible that in this
race the only country the land of the
rising sun beats is north korea well
visualpolitik fans the key seems to lie
in corporate operations let me explain
in a typical developed country up to 80
of fdi inflows take the form of
corporate mergers and acquisitions
however that is not the case in japan it
seems to be a legacy of the immediate
post-world war ii era
[Music]
at that time tokyo restricted fdi to
prevent foreign companies from taking
control of the market years later when
entry into the oecd forced the japanese
government to overturn these
restrictions japanese policymakers
divide countermeasures of sorts to make
it more difficult for multinationals to
buy japanese companies a large part of
these countermeasures had to do with the
promotion of crushed shareholdings
between companies and above all with the
return of a large conglomerates the
kuritsu to give you an idea today these
conglomerates continue to exercise
enormous control over the national
economy the karitsu controls 26 000
parent companies 56 000 subsidiaries and
employ about 18 million people almost a
third of all japanese employees and this
is not even counting many companies that
act as subcontractors and suppliers
closely linked to these groups the
toyota group for example has some 1 000
subsidiaries and 40 000 suppliers most
of which are closely linked to this
group in other words in practice they're
not entirely independent in this way the
kuritsu exercises such control over
japanese companies that they leave
little room for foreign corporations to
gain a foothold it is something like a
very closed ecosystem the problem is
that the ecosystem is so close that in
many fields it has fueled enormous
inbreeding that comes at the expense of
productivity and change for example the
digital transition in japan lags far
behind its counterpart countries
to make matters worse despite its
intentions the government has introduced
even more control mechanisms for example
in 2020 it pushed through parliament a
change in the foreign exchange and
foreign trade law to lower the threshold
by which a corporate transaction
requires government approval from 10 of
the shares it dropped to around one
percent the result is that buying a
company in japan can be an almost
impossible mission and that explains the
very little fdi that enters the country
in relative terms however this is
something that could start to change
very soon for three main reasons
[Music]
firstly surveys are beginning to show
greater social acceptance of foreigners
taking control of local companies this
is something that has traditionally
generated dread in the country secondly
demographic decline is forcing many
small and medium-sized enterprises to
close their as their owners retire and
have no successors among these lines in
2020 a report published by the fdi
promotion council a government advisory
body argued that foreign capital inflow
could be the solution to this problem we
are talking about more than 600 000
profitable smes that might have to close
within the next three years there are
six million jobs at risk and thirdly
plans to raise the economic growth and
profitability of the tokyo stock
exchange and driving changes in the
corporate governance policies of
companies we'll tell you about it in an
upcoming video so don't forget to
subscribe to all of us here at
visualpolitik to stay in the loop
however as we have mentioned on other
occasions this is not the only area
where japan's economy has become the odd
one out in terms of economic
globalization check this out
[Music]
a country that is also close to talent
in contrast to most developed countries
japan has a fairly small immigrant
population barely two percent of the
total in the united states for example
that figure exceeds 13 not only has this
meant exploding a lot of talent but has
also contributed to deepening the
demographic crisis the country is
experiencing its population first began
to decline in 2005 and it's been
steadily shrinking since 2011 which is
taking a major toll on the working age
population for example in 2019 more than
28 of the population was over the age of
65 and only about 60 of japanese
residents were between the ages of 15
and 64. this explains why this country
suffers from one of the highest levels
of labor shortages in all developed
countries
[Music]
according to the japanese government
itself we are talking about a shortage
of 6.5 million workers by 2030. so far
some changes have already been
introduced to encourage the arrival of
foreign labor but everything indicates
that things will have to move faster in
the future and so visualpolitik viewers
you can see that in some fields the
japanese economy is the most close to
international flows but that is about to
undergo a huge transformation the
question is will it be enough to balance
all of the problems the country is
facing will japan become the new
fashionable destination for
multinationals these are questions that
only time can answer for now leave us
your thoughts below in the comments and
very importantly if you have found this
video that we have made in collaboration
with our friends from value school
interesting don't forget to like it and
leave us your impressions in the
comments all the best and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you